[Music]  Prince Harry brings all the laughs to  veterans on Founders Day the Duke of  Sussex looked dapper during his solo  Thursday outing to the Royal Hospital  Chelsea in West London where he cracked  jokes while meeting with a few of the  300 plus army veterans who call the  retirement facility home  after greeting the crowd the Royal  delivered a speech complete with his  signature width of course there was also  the annual Founders Day parade which  celebrates the founding of the hospital  in 1681 by king charles ii this year it  also honored the 75th anniversary of the  d-day invasion Harry and wife Megan  Markel commemorated the occasion by  posting a few adorable photos on their  Instagram account as for why mmm wasn't  at Thursday's festivities she's still on  maternity leave I had the two best guys  in the world  it's been exactly one month since the  Duke and Duchess welcomed son Archie  Harrison into the world I'm just over  the moon  [Music]